poverty is pushing millions of desperate
people to defy India's lockdown orders
it's a basic matter of survival this
landfill just outside of New Delhi has
become a lifeline for the past few days
I've been eating whatever I can find
here look here there's some bread there
are biscuits I'm going to eat them he
and others scour heaps of waste looking
for whatever they can survive on now and
live on later
I can't resell anything at the moment
but after lockdown when the market
reopens I'll try to sell it to contain
the coronavirus the Indian government
has chosen to confine all of its 1.3
billion residents success varies city to
city state to state some areas are
eerily empty with few people venturing
out but for the millions living below
the poverty line confinement isn't an
option I had a good life and all of a
sudden my kids and I lost our jobs
everything closed down this is no way to
live what are we going to eat the
pandemic has dried up work and caused a
mass exodus
he will die anyway either from hunger or
coronavirus under these conditions it's
best to return to the village at least
there are relatives we'll be able to
bury us with dignity but while the poor
flee they could potentially spread a
virus throughout the country making the
fight against covet 19 even tougher to
win DWS Nimisha joist wall is standing
by for us in Delhi Nimisha as we saw in
that report the lockdown is having
devastating effects for so many in India
how long is it likely to continue well
Rebekkah are the three week lockdown
currently in place officially runs out
next week but we are expecting a
decision and announcement from the prime
minister later today about if this
lockdown will be extended or not he is
going to be video conferencing with
local leaders across the country for a
decision
on the extension of the slack lockdown
already some states have extended this
lockdown till the end of April but we
have to note here that even before the
pandemic hit India was in the midst of
an economic slowdown and the lockdown
has definitely had an impact already and
it's likely to have a resonating impact
so the decision going forward is going
to be of course about containing the
spread of the virus but also ensuring
that some sectors that need to be
revitalized all start functioning
however the government has emphasized
that things cannot go back to normal
social distancing will be a norm for
months to come
so the laughlin is obviously a necessary
measure but what is the government doing
to help those most vulnerable back our
government announced measures to feed
the feed the forests of the word feed
Judah microns in urban centers in cities
like Delhi there are food kitchens that
have been opened across the city there
are direct cash transfers being made to
construction workers and female laborers
however the government has received
heavy criticism for what was seen as
poor planning when the slop town was
announced perhaps right alongside a
lockdown if these measures had been
announced the pool could have had no
confidence and stayed in place instead
of the exodus we saw right at the
beginning of the lockdown when so many
rural migrants fled home in addition the
government should have also ramped up
security measures to ensure that this
the the impact on the poor could have
been cooked so of course if the lockdown
was extended this is going to be a key
area where we are going to have to see
if the government is going to ramp up
protections and help make a choice
voluntarily thanks very much